a question yeah which would you rather
see
a guy who you're really really into once
every two weeks
or a guy you're only kind of into twice
a week
the first one the first one the first
one as well because my dating style is
very much i'm quite independent and i
work i work in film i work quite a
demanding job sometimes i can be on set
for 12 hours yeah i or longer i've
worked in a job before i was on for 16
hours yeah sweet sweet over time
but um so as many because you're busy
right a busy and also just in general my
both of my parents are quite independent
people
my mum loves to sit at home and read
she's she's she's very
she's she's so neutral she's so she's so
calm my mom has such a calming presence
in my life and my dad is like me and my
dad is bat [ __ ] and i love it but my
parents they work so well together
because no one could date my dad like my
mom and no one could date my mom like my
dad and they balance each other out
really well and they are both very
independent people and they're very
happy to do their own thing they don't
need to be in each other's space all the
time and i really like that and that's
something i like now and the thing that
i admire and i tend to date people who
are busy bodies and people who are
ambitious and things because that's the
quality i have and i also like people
who who uh who want to do other things
and i'm not their soul hobby no i'm not
saying you do cool with a boyfriend you
see twice a month
sure so
the reason the reason i asked that
question is because i think
it's exactly that reason
that
the date in landscape is the way it is
now because most girls would rather
see the guy they really want
less
than the guy who's ready to be there for
them more
i think which end which is how you end
up having one guy
having six seven eight nine girls
because they would all wrong i don't
know why you're laughing
uh but rather
is this what's happening to you at the
moment absolutely
no but it's true but it's true though
like they'd rather see they'd their like
they draw this [ __ ] do you know do you
know man
i know
you know
a couple yeah but
but i would i would say who wants to see
someone that they kind of like of course
everybody wants to see the blessings
what i'm trying to say is like they're i
think before they used to prioritize
commitment
a bit not over quality but
more compared to quality but now it's
like we only care about quality and if
it means i only get five percent of him
that i'd rather take that but i don't
think the amount of time you spend with
someone equates commitment look at
long-term relationships you can still be
in a really commit relationship if it's
a long uh uh if it's long distance sorry
not long-term if it's a long-distance
relationship you don't think there's a
higher level of commitment if you're
like living with someone oh yeah like i
mean but i think it depends on what
framework if you've got bills if you've
got shared bills of course that is right
like that's that is a commitment because
you you both financially have to
supplies like if one of you loses a job
it's like
great
but i think i i i think that people want
different things i know a lot of women
and i know a lot of men who are much
more dependent people and they want to
be with their partner a lot and that's
fine those people tend to find each
other
i think it just depends what kind of
person you are and i think a lot of it
depends how you're raised as well like
if you're raised with parents who love
to be with each other all the time then
i think you learn by that behavior and
you go this is what a healthy
relationship looks like
and to me i think not being in each
other's space all the time is what i
prefer but for me i'm like okay if you
love being around each other that's
great i still love being around my
partners don't get me wrong it's just
that if i'm working a really long job if
i've got loads of other stuff and i've
got a lot of friends and i want to see
those guys too and i think that's okay i
think if you see someone if you're
living with them like of course i'm
gonna see my partner more i've never i
you know i've not lived with any of my
partners so i'm not having that natural
kind of being around them when i come
home thing in which case i would see
them more
so so coming off his question right say
if you're seeing a guy like every two
weeks
at a certain point like obviously you
guys sleep together like every two weeks
what not after say like five months
i feel like it's safe to say at some
point you'd want to see more
uh
if you
are progressing in terms of oh okay now
we're gonna buy a house together or
we're gonna move in together then oh no
no no if you want to take them seriously
just yeah like a serious relationship
because i i feel like
when i gotta go sleep together at some
point
the girl is gonna be like cool like two
weeks is a bit of a long time like i i'd
like to know that a lot so once you
narrow it a lot and you tell them you're
like look i'm trying to see more often
and he's like
i kind of like it the way it is
i think i think it depends i think it
depends what as well what his reasons is
if it's like sorry i can only see you
two weeks because i'm away for work or
i'm doing this or whatever you go okay
fair enough and also again this is we're
talking within a heteronormative and
monogamous relationship we're not
accounting for anything like polyamory
but if you of you if you're dating
someone monogamously
yeah sometimes people have careers
let me ask the guys um
you guys had had a girlfriend
yeah ever ever yeah ever would they have
been cool with seeing you twice a month
no chance
no chance now i actually um one of my
relationships my longest term
relationship ended because
of long distance
and just not seeing each other as
frequently
um
yeah distance is the worst i don't think
long-distance relationships work oh my
god i yeah i tried that it crashed and
burned
i've tried that too
i think unless you have plans in place
to make it not long distance i don't
think it's sustainable what do you
consider distance like an hour two hours
three i'd say
enough distance where if you couldn't
if they had a really bad day and you
couldn't see them that evening
because they're too far it's too far
it's gonna be like two hours
i'd say five to be honest
you don't think that's what you do you
meet someone to have a bad day for like
four hours
well if they're like five hours away
if they're four hours away if you like
but my my long distance she was in
australia like oh yeah oh oh so anything
closer than that i think i could
probably do america uk somewhere that's
it
really because you got the time
difference i mean same with you as well
you've got a time difference yeah
there's only so many hours like it's
like a window where you can really like
chat to each other yeah yeah yeah yeah
so
if you missed that